for the latest mini election trip i'm
off to Margate in Kent for you Kip
spring conference i'll be speaking to
Patrick O'Flynn MEP and the party's
economic spokesman about their plans for
tackling the deficit splintering
factions within you kid and how
important nudge for us is in holding it
all together and how much of today's
conference was about Nigel you said that
you gave one the pekin one the best
speeches you've ever seen him give and
it seemed to me that that was the main
thing of the day you know you gave a
speech but the crowd really got going
for Nigel doesn't in order to show that
the party's about Nigel and not much
else well clearly we're very fortunate
in having a very inspirational leader
who's not only a major national
political figure but a major
international political figure now and
you saw the buzz and and there's no
doubt when you get 40 camera crews and a
huge posse of press journalists as well
when he leaves the stage that
communicates the party that you know
we're serious players and our leaders
are very important part of that
absolutely and since the wag tax fiasco
which I'm sure you remember well and
would you say you're still close with
Nigel you're still got good input winter
what he thinks yeah absolutely and you
know Nigel leads the party from from its
centre and I suppose it's it's a sign of
the growth of you kit that we're now
held to have a right wing and a left
wing which one of you on well I read
that I'm left of center which was su
kare well that will certainly come as a
surprise to I think readers long-term
readers of The Daily Express to consider
that I am I'm ranked on on the left of a
party but it's all relative isn't it um
so I'm seeing I suppose as being a more
personally wants to go in that direction
of giving a big offer to the blue-collar
working people people who start off the
vet with very little and feel that that
the the state doesn't back them that the
society they're growing up and is not on
their side and tap into that there are
you know I would say a smaller number
much more a number of you know more
traditionally
hardline libertarian so that was what
the party was before the last few years
you know before you join in that sort of
thing that was the call of you Kip no I
think you'll find there's very long term
members who've come from the Labour
Party and we're very fortunate as a
party in that the policy that we all
agree is the most important thing we
have one hundred percent unity on and I
don't think any other parties could say
that and finally if you immigration arts
are the top two messages you give a push
in believe in Britain your slogan where
does the economy come into how important
is that well the the state of the
economy is intimately linked to our EU
membership and via uncontrolled
immigration we're talking about the
economy I think in a much broader
accessible way to working people we're
talking about living standards and wage
rates you know and youth unemployment
and wage compression in general and the
impact on communities of uncontrolled
immigration and I think it is that
estranged probably people from families
which once considered themselves as
reflexively labor who feel that the
Labour Party doesn't speak for them
anymore who are coming to us in the
biggest numbers and you're not just
talking about those issue because it's
easier than talking about debt and
deficit and that sort of thing well I
think I talked about debt and deficit
quite a lot and you know I have said the
ambition of you Kip is to hold the next
Chancellor's feet to the fire on the
Treasury deficit elimination plan you
know they set out a plan five years ago
and it didn't happen it didn't even
nearly happen so again a reasonably
punchy plan to get rid of the deficit
was set out in the autumn statement it
seems perfectly reasonable to me for a
country that's been in significant
public sector deficit since 2002 but
it's about time we got rid of that and
so you know I think it's up to every
party to set out where it would save the
money and you know we've set out a very
large sum of savings in areas that none
of the other parties are prepared to
adopt or to match so you know compared
to us they've got about 25 billion
pounds of savings to identify and you
know I am waiting I'm waiting see how
the Tories plan to fund the various tax
cuts they promised at their party
conference and David Cameron are
said we've got a record so trust us well
the record on the 40 Pete extra
shoulders to a that they've aggressively
lowered it that's the record on that you
know the record on on net migration is
not the one that he set out to achieve
either that's it for this mini election
adventure join me again soon to find out
how the election is being fought in a
different part of the country find out
more at mini election co uk